Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel in.
My name is Paul.
Today we're going to talk about the
language of pigeons.
Sorry,
I know that joke isn't very good,
but that's all I've got.
Today.
I'm going to talk about some special
kinds of languages called pigeons and
creoles.
You've probably heard those terms
before,
maybe in the names of certain languages
like pigeon English or Haitian Creole,
but please note there is not just a
single pigeon language or a single
creole language.
They are actually referring to
categories of languages.
There are many pigeons and many creoles
around the world.
First,
what do they have in common?
Well,
pigeons and creoles are new languages
that develop when speakers of different
languages come into contact with each
other and have a need to communicate.
Many pigeons and creoles have arisen
when colonial powers came into contact
with local people as they spread around
the world.
So what's the difference between pigeons
and creoles?
Well,
pigeons are non native,
Lingua Franca as well.
Creoles have native speakers,
but let me get into both types of
language.
First of all,
Pidgin languages,
as I just mentioned,
Pidgin languages have no native speakers
there.
Languages that arise very suddenly,
very quickly when there is a need for
communication in a certain situation.
For example,
for trade or for Labor,
the pigeon language is a sort of
compromise between two different
languages or between multiple languages.
Pigeons usually arise when one group of
people is dominant over another group of
people and the less dominant group needs
to learn to communicate with the more
dominant group,
but without any formal education in the
language of that dominant group,
they adopt the sort of simplified
language based on the most basic
vocabulary of that dominant groups
language and based on the most basic
grammar of their own native language.
This happens most commonly in situations
of trade slavery or colonial contact,
and in a situation like that,
the dominant group is usually the
colonial power or the most influential
trading partner.
Imagine this situation,
an English speaking.
Colonial power has a sugar plantation
and they bring over at laborers from
various different countries to that
sugar plantation and those people speak
different languages,
but in order to work together,
they need to have a common language so
they try to adopt English,
but since they do this quickly and they
just adopt the basics,
the resulting language is a very
simplified language.
Just using the basic vocabulary of
English and a very non English grammar
that is a pidgin language.
When pigeons first developed,
they are typically restricted in use,
meaning that they are only used for a
certain purpose,
for example,
on the job or for trade,
but something pigeons become expanded
pigeons,
meaning that they begin to be used for
all facets of life,
including social life,
family life,
things like that,
and they become languages in their own
rights.
Even though they are not native
languages.
They are passed down from generation to
generation as lingua.
Franca is amongst people who speak a
different native languages now about
creole languages,
so pigeons have no native speakers.
They arise because of the need for a
Lingua Franca,
but if that language survives and
becomes the native language of the next
generation than it is now a creole
language,
for example,
slaves from several different countries
are working closely together on a
plantation,
but they have no common language,
so they develop their pigeon and it
quickly becomes their expanded pigeon,
the language they use for all everyday
purposes.
Their children grow up in that
environment with that pigeon language
and it becomes their native language
that is now a creole language.
In the days when African slaves were
brought to the Americas,
they were often separated from people
who spoke the same native language.
That was to prevent them from rebelling
or from making plans together,
that kind of thing.
So in those kinds of situations,
the pidgin languages became expanded
very quickly and within one generation
sometimes became creoles.
Some creoles are based on English,
for example,
Jamaican Creole,
some creoles are based on French,
including Haitian Creole,
which has 12 million native speakers,
and the smaller number of creole
languages are based on Spanish,
including Chava in Philippines.
Now,
how different are these creole languages
from their parent languages?
Well,
it depends on the particular language,
but let's look at an example.
This example is from Bislama,
which is an English based creole spoken
to you in Vanuatu.
The first sentence is,
this is my house in Bislama,
heavier house belong me or in more
standard English phonology.
Kim here,
house belong me.
Another example sentence.
I have already been to town in Bislama
me been longterm fitness or in standard
English phonology.
Me being that long,
the town's finish.
So look at each word.
Meat is like I been.
That's self explanatory.
Long is used as a preposition here
instead of an adjective,
so long means toward or two.
And then we have town that's like town
and finish finishes used instead of
already to show that something has been
accomplished.
So again,
you can see that the words are from
English,
but they're used and arranged in a very
different way and this is what makes it
a different language than the parent
language.
Pigeons and creoles are fascinating
because they are proof that languages
are living entities that are constantly
changing and adapting to the needs of
their speakers.
Sometimes two or more languages can even
join forces and take on a life of their
own as a new language.
Thank you for watching.
Be sure to leave your comments down
below and have a nice
day.